well of course as you say last weekend
we had a combination of factors so we
had bad weather a big increase and
traffic volumes particularly coaches and
and actually we had returned to
pre-pandemic coach levels
um but now in a post-brexit environment
and so the requirement for checks on
passports of every individual all of
those factors uh came together and
resulted in this significant delays and
as a result Freight was also affected
and Brunei also in a busy period and the
Easter break again we expect an increase
in tourism volume so they're not
expected to be as high as last weekend
but around 80 percent or 86 percent of
our freight drivers currently using the
port are non-uk residents so essentially
they're trying to get home and they're
trying to do so ahead of this Sunday
French restrictions on driving so we're
working with Camp residience Forum
keeping it very close eye on the
situation and ensuring that we through
social media and other avenues are
keeping our members updated
so what could the impact be on consumers
what's most likely to be affected is it
Goods coming into the country or Goods
going out it would be good going out
um and obviously when you have a
situation like this where there are
delays it puts stress on the supply
chain it also has an impact on our
drivers if they're waiting considerable
periods of time it becomes a driver
welfare issue and so that's why we're
working very closely with the Kent
resilience forum and to make sure that
we can minimize delays in fact I have a
number of meetings today as we closely
monitor the situation and make sure the
contingency plans are in place if needed
and people are working very hard in that
and our message to Mr members would be
to check with your Ferry operator to
make sure that you're aware of the
latest guidance make sure that you've
completed all your paperwork and before
you head there and have supplies there
and just in case and make sure that you
leave enough time to accommodate any
delays
some people worry that this is going to
happen every time there's some kind of
holiday are you concerned about that and
and what would you like done about it
well we are calling um on the government
to make sure that it's working with all
of the partners to streamline the
processes because we what we don't want
to happen is that this becomes a default
situation every time we have a holiday
period or a pick in traffic and we're
also very conscious too that it looks
like it'll be next year but the EU will
be introducing a new entry and exit
scheme as well around biometric security
so it's really important and that the
government leads on this work that it
works with all of its Partners to make
sure that we're streamlining processes
that things are moving as effectively
and as efficiently as possible so that
we can keep Goods moving because this
particular port on the short streets is
the key Logistics and trading route
there are some 3 million Freight
vehicles that pass through it every year
so it's essential that we all work
together to get it right what does
streamlining processes mean and given
that all passports individually have to
be checked now so everybody on a coach
has to be checked how do you speed that
up well it certainly is challenging
because if we look at the Port of Dover
and people that are working extremely
hard there are constraints around the
site geography so it's about looking and
working together to see how we can
through maybe digitalization technology
and that we can make sure that their
systems in place to make things move as
quickly as possible because particularly
in the case of Port of Dover speed is of
the essence in terms of making sure that
people and goods are able to flow as
quickly as possible so we will continue
to work with the government on that it
published a draft Target operating model
and just this week there's a lot of
change happening around the border and
the government needs to make sure that
that is all joined up that it is brought
together that it is simplified that it
is streamlined that it works for
tourists but critically that it also
works for our freed operators and those
who make sure that we all get the goods
that we need when we need them